This is still a very serious issue.
And I'm really disappointed
because I had two different local news agencies
reach out to me here in San Diego
regarding this.
In the public health crisis
that is happening at our border.
And both of the reporters
had to drop the stories completely
because the news agencies did not wanna move forward
covering that topic.
One in seven,
one in seven patients that jump the border wall die.
Many of, if not most of the rest of them
have life altering,
debilitating injuries from doing so.
The amount of 15 and 16 year old girls
I have taken care of
who have been in that situation
is insane. Now
here in San Diego
there are actually two walls.
The first wall is 18 feet tall,
the next wall is 30.
That is a three story building
that people are falling from.
Under the Trump administration,
the height of the border wall was increased by 10 feet.
And the only reason that the height was increased
was in order to kill and maim immigrants.
And according to research that has been done
by the university of California at San Diego,
that height increase also LED to an increase
increase in serious injury and death
by 600%. 600%.
They know that nothing will stop people from jumping.
These are people that have nothing left,
have no other option.
They are doing it to kill and main people.
As a healthcare worker,
it is insane.
To me that the public is not aware of this.
We're talking young kids. Young kids.
If this is a topic that you are passionate about,
I implore you to follow border kindness on Instagram. Um,
Border Kindness is a non profit organization that helps
care for immigrants who are detained
and not detained at the border.
And right now,
there are a lot of people in
specifically
the Hokoba Springs area in Southern California
who are being detained by Border Patrol,
without food,
without shelter,
without, like,
Protection from the elements.
These are people that are, like,
with their young kids,
just stuck out in the elements.
There is absolutely a crisis at our border,
but it is not what Fox News is telling you,
and it is entirely being perpetrated by Border Patrol,
who also also has,
like, 600 recent cases of essaying minors.
So just keep that in mind.